this is the Lodi an African lion these  stunning big cats are Africa's apex  predator they once roamed most of Africa  and parts of Europe and Asia but today  they are only found in parts of  sub-saharan Africa Zawadi is a male lion  indicated by his large main lions are  considered the only social member of the  cat family and live in large groups  called pride females do most of the  hunting and work in teams ambushing  their prey their importance to the  ecosystem is paramount playing a key  role in the food chain  controlling herbivore populations but  while they are the alpha predators they  face threats of their own a combination  of trophy hunting and habitat loss has  cut their population in half over the  past two decades  this is the African lion  [Music]